gang you only got three more chances to
see are you garbage live yeah guys
december 14th 15th and 16th we're going
to be in hartford connecticut at the
funny bone we're going to be in albany
new york at the funny bone that we're
going to be in syracuse new york at the
funny bone as well
guys this is a great way to introduce
your friends to the show if you're
coming bring a couple of pounds bring
this squad it's a good time it's stand
up we're hanging out play auig you've
seen the clips what are you doing come
out we'll see you there let's go
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
are you garbage uh-huh it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they're good
to be classy yeah that's just a big old
piece of [ __ ] oh boy i'm your host dates
foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here in aunt dodie's basement
she's a little upset why is that
breathalyzer's going in the car tomorrow
wow
yeah that's how they get you those ain't
cheap either and she's driving uber now
so that's [ __ ] real that's gonna be
real [ __ ] dicey my co-host is coming
at you from across the table so you know
it's a family episode we're circling the
wagons we're doing the patreon questions
just the homies and the bozos this week
baby yeah just the way we like it give
it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available over there
on a youtube and as you know those
numbers are true to real just at 29k
thank you thank you very much as of this
morning we we broke over uh 29 000. and
gang you're gonna want to subscribe
there's gonna be some stuff dropping on
there later on you wanna you wanna be a
part of it's funny when it rains it
pours cause when we when we hit a
certain mark on the old patreon there
that thing started [ __ ] talking
guns out and i had two new waitresses
where people couldn't get ombuds at the
table they're cooking over there
kidding me
i had the busboy taking orders yeah uh
hot also as uh my co-host has alluded to
it at patreon.com are you garbage you
can sign up you get a [ __ ] ton of bonus
content i'm talking
ebsa ayg epsom hard feelings which
is the fan favorite i gotta be honest
everybody loves hard feelings we pull
back the curtain a little bit we we have
a little bit of an hr type thing too the
airing of grievances
yeah you really get to see our [ __ ]
demented relationship
we truly have that we've pulled toby
into
uh he's crazy now too yeah he's crazy
and he also plays like the sun i can see
the role he used to play in your family
of like peacemaker a little bit cause
sometimes with me and the big man are
going at it and he goes he goes hey guys
they're all having fun right hey look
over here just i'm in the back seat of
the honda civic again just yeah and i'm
so out of line
i'm sitting there i'm like he thinks i'm
falling for this you [ __ ] he's lucky i
don't [ __ ] turn my sights on him
check it out gang we're having a lot of
fun over here on a patreon get in the
cabinet under the kitchen sink and stay
there yeah [ __ ] until you still you
stop hearing the sound of dishes
the adults are communicating
because we get after it on there did you
ever have that you ever see proper
dishes getting smashed
no there was uh i used to
i used to sit at my uh
when i would be at my my dad's house
would sit in the i'd be upstairs in my
bedroom watching tv
right you know probably some wrestling
or something you know
and uh
you would hear like maybe that's yelling
and then i hit mute i'm like oh that's
their it's toe to toe down there they're
going out nothing like catching the show
at the top of the steps
you know yeah when you creep out like
what the [ __ ] happening oh this is
normal all right i go back oh this is
just normal normal yelling at your dad's
blades he's just throwing paper plates
and solo cups
we
he was doing well
it was waterford crystal
that's good stuff did we talk about
tebow mcmuffin did you did you mention
the kid that's your job why am i doing
your job t-bone mcmuffin
guy
good to see you buddy what's up dudes
hey t-bonios we're chillin we're cold
chillin i thought of something
you mentioned one of my favorite words
uh mayonnaise
a couple minutes ago before we started
broadcasting here uh but i i noticed
something at the airport when we were
flying down to houston
um
you asked for mayo at breakfast
i like i like mayo with my fries and or
home fries
wow i went over the uk i saw how they
did it original style i was like that is
disgusting and then i tried it and i was
like ketchup is out for life maya with
the fries maybe a pinch of ketchup but
it is unbelievable mayo and fries that's
the biggest a little too tangy for my
taste
on paper it is disgusting in practice
you're like this is the way this is why
i did it back in the day in belgium as
you know i'm an international man of
mystery and business
and sexual proclivity
kid likes it weird
i uh he walks through the red light
district they turn them all off
hippies in town
[ __ ] tumbleweed flies
the big-headed american has returned
um we eat it anyway
they call it we call it
we call it
a remulod sure that's mayonnaise-based
sure it's the same [ __ ] i'm just saying
all bay and there these americans will
eat it i've had it up [ __ ] ton you know
that's what they do in germany over i'm
over there and i'm over there in europe
a whole bunch and that's what they do
that's the go to
catch up in mile can i say that even
though i joke about i am looking forward
to actually having a french fry
okay
trying french fries in france and the
toast i hear is good
sure i was curious about that though
yeah that was why i heard that that's
how they did it originally in belgium i
saw him doing it in the uk and i was
like i'll try i'll take this for a walk
i thought for a minute you were putting
it on your eggs that's i would have had
a [ __ ] call for separate checks if
that was yeah that's that's that ain't
happening in my neck of the woods that's
bonkos
i did want to bring up another thing
believe it or not food related
thanks not coming listen you know
yo sorry i feel like you do kind of make
not as many fat jokes sorry no that's
okay please let him fly i'm in therapy i
can take it yeah i can tell
our pre-show conversation was real cool
this guy's [ __ ]
[ __ ] hopping a jet out of here
i'm like literally i'm like why the [ __ ]
did i tell him to get into therapy oh
man oh talking about worms i just go the
next five years of my life is gonna suck
this bro better start fixing me
um
this is a little specific what
so and you think i do it nowadays
uh sour cream hummus is a big one
yogurts dips whatever they have the
cellophane on top that's stuck to it
sure now here's my question
i'm asking i know what i know where
you're going do you take it all the way
off and throw it out and that's it once
you open the container oh do you [ __ ]
leave it halfway hanging on there like a
goddamn dirt bag listen that's
disgusting
it depends who's around really yeah what
do you mean
if i'm i'm a lazy man by nature as well
while i'm a go-getter uh i tell you but
you need you need the the
i don't want that cramming up to i can
no i can't it's going there typically
yes but i feel like i for sure have with
uh hummus where i have it it's also two
it depends where i'm at if i get it and
i'm out say i'm sitting on the couch
right i'm enjoying uh you know some uh
sabra some some some stacy's pita chips
and some sabra
stacy's pizzas
man you gotta have your [ __ ] dental
plan up with those things
they'll [ __ ] crack a tooth dude they
tear the roof of your mouth oh my god up
cut them in half chewing firecrackers
stace what are you doing cut them in
half oh i love it but dude i go this is
gonna [ __ ] me and i love every second of
it those parmesan's garlic parmesan
doggy they're all right um
i got a follow-up for you when you peel
that that that cellophane
that's what i thought you were going
with i do not i can't bring myself to do
that
but
uh it depends where i'm at if i'm in the
kitchen i'll open it and throw it out
but like if i go
say i'm sitting on a couch or something
like oh i don't want this just it gets
on your knuckles and [ __ ] i understand i
understand it's not ideal my girl does
it it drives me [ __ ] crazy she won't
take it off won't take it off
yeah it drives me nice yikes even the
yogurt too in the fridge it has that
that like paper on it when you get the
good [ __ ] so get rid of that crap yeah i
will say a yogurt cup little individual
john that that lid that's a guaranteed
lick that's getting oh yeah
especially a pudding at a pudding with a
nice clump on top
hello
[Music]
yeah good time are you licking the top
of your meal plan cell phone because
that's stuff and easy to get off have
you noticed that they're [ __ ]
impossible oh my you got to have that
thing i'm putting that thing in a full
nelson to get that off and i might
impossible i can't i can't have any of
that on there it drives me crazy yeah
drives me [ __ ] nuts um i haven't
really had anything to lick on there
okay i don't know what you're doing
[Laughter]
mine's all hummus
yeah hmm but
was that all you had is that what was it
yeah i was curious about that yeah yeah
curious what you what your thoughts were
on it because i'll go either in an
optimal situation i throw it out if a
trash can is near me but like say i'm
like you know in one of my comfy spots
and i don't want to like you know put it
on the couch or i just i'll i'll leave
it and then like i'll do it later and
here's my thing prolonging it here's my
thing what's your thing i'm a child of
the 80s okay all right like ronald
reagan just as much as the next american
i'm reaganing um
i know there was issues back then with
you know [ __ ] some psycho putting
this and that or poisoning this or
poison that but we've really over
corrected it i don't think do you need
all you're trying to get that thing off
there
you feel you're like [ __ ] larry david
trying to [ __ ] pull that [ __ ] off
it's [ __ ] brutal i get it it's too
much but dude tell me if you just got
nine caps
yeah you need it though man why there's
some [ __ ] twisted people really dude
if you could just go open up hummus just
like this put one of these things you
don't see mountain dew doing that [ __ ]
what do you mean they just have a
regular twisty there's not a foil on top
of the mountain dew when i take a cap
off and there's another thing there it's
like what the what is this
yeah that's [ __ ] ocean's eleven
that's what like you're talking like
tropicana or something don't even get me
started with that thing you got to open
that thing up and then pull it off
that's drives me nuts that's the cotton
and the pills what do we do with the
cotton and the pills
so it's not as loud
packs them in there oh really yeah i
don't know that's my theory i've kind of
for sure might have just made that up
because i would just picture like if i
was working on one of those factors like
this is so loud [ __ ] pack that thing
a little bit
put a little [ __ ] styrofoam in there
give me a headache
that's well that's how i would feel
um but yeah all right so as you know
this is a family yes it is episode yes
it is and we're gonna get into some of
your uh some of your garbage questions
cause we love you so goddamn much out
there all the bozos and the homies
uh we got a couple of heaters here so
guys as you know when you sign up for
patreon we will um
we will answer your question on air on
the air
uh i think we had a big backlog we've
worked i've worked through a bunch we're
we're relatively relevant and also not
everybody likes to ask questions yeah
people just hang in the back you know
um
this one's called from dirty [ __ ]
house i don't know yeah uh thank you mom
this one's [ __ ] i've never thought of
this when you go to a public bathroom is
it garbage to sit on someone else's
toilet seat bed
oh my god like they've left
the toilet seat which is a protection
dirt bag move like if the the liner i
know what you're talking about that's
insane that's crazy that i would never
do i'd rather sit dude i'd rather sit on
the toilet with the lid up lit up yeah
yeah you know what i mean no of course
of course i've done that in the middle
of the night lit up sit no go to take a
deuce in the middle of the night and the
[ __ ] the lid's up and you sit down on
on the porcelain
it's never drizzy to me we're not
turning the light on
boom boom sometimes
poop in the dark
no i'll pee in the dark and i gotta be
honest if i'm peeing in the dark it's a
[ __ ]
i'm just i'm aiming i'm going north
south east or west i'm not i'm not
getting any tighter than that i guess
i'm in the direction i guess it's the
weight i don't know but i'm man i am
terrible it's the weight i've shared a
lot of airbnb's i'm peeing i pee all
over this there's there's dribbles
not even dribbles they start in the
living room the stream will like just
[ __ ] go sideways you guys throwing
curveballs down there oh yeah
yeah can't get a radar lock on it that's
it's and it's a lot it's like
you know do you have at your current
bathroom do you have a rug under it
right there no we have a we have a a rug
that goes next to the tub which in the
middle of the night i'll
take my foot put my foot on that rug
slide it over
clean it up and then put it back
like it never happened
that's how i do it you need a backup
camera for your dumps
onstar how can i help
yeah i'm trying to think of [ __ ] over
here
[Laughter]
yeah that's
it's getting bad or a god bed now now
we're going the other way we're working
on it sure of course which crap you can
check out fat court on patreon
um this one's not just from blaine smith
have you ever used armor all to shine
your shoes
which i guess if they're black shoes
that makes sense
but i can't
that's insane we use windex i have to
shy we'd have to shine my dad's navy
shoes with windex windex is that like
they were the patent leather like the no
they were like shiny they were like
texting
yeah patented that's patent leather is
it yeah really yeah a patent leather
crazy um
windex armor all sucks kinda you cannot
get that off you i know you literally
and it doesn't clean that well it does
yeah
i'm more of a rainx guy that product
blows my mind on the windshield oh man i
don't think i've ever used it oh you can
tell
such a difference
put on your forehead
i'm the new spokesman
it even works on your forehead
little white hi i'm kippy from are you
garbage your eyebrows just start going
you have a huge forehead
who's the guy that does flex seal
it was billy mays but he yacked out now
it's some other bozo looks just like him
yeah i don't know you know who i liked i
like that british guy sully or whatever
he's a good [ __ ] i would love to get one
of those guys on the show oh man come on
who's the british guy
sully i think his name is does he have
glasses no that's the guy with the
question he might be australian
no i think he's british
he's like a big tall drink of water real
regular everyday kind of guy real real
everyday kind of bloke you know what i
miss those i miss those infomercials
like that i think they're still there
probably more than ever now yeah yeah i
used to love watching ron popeil [ __ ]
did you ever see the chicken relax you
ever see the guy who sells knives who
continuously cuts himself
he's cut himself
45 it's a real background sketch it is
it's it's bad it's real low budget and
he consistently
consistently
bleeds on the show that's every figure
has been oh dude and he goes i got it's
real [ __ ]
it's a whole thing there's a montage of
it on youtube i believe it's really
funny talk about appetite or did you
ever see that uh you know whatever the
perfect ladder or whatever and it
supports qvc and it collapses
that guy [ __ ] that guy folds in half
dude
shout out to guys getting hurt on tv ah
it's good stuff nothing's better it's
good times man good that was one of the
first real viral videos way back in the
day was the the newscaster squashing
grapes oh yeah oh
oh man
that chubby broad went head over heels
dude
that was some good [ __ ] good stuff you
know what really gets you going
especially over on the road and i know
you like the you like the guy it was one
of the old original ones the news
reporter who was there for the death at
the school and the bug flies in his
mouth
that will get the big mac how's that guy
doing just a fake voice they're
newscasters they're all fake they're all
[ __ ] ah thanks
and
ah good stuff this one
this happens a lot all right this is
from uh from uh
bozone i guess oh bozo but it's b-e-a-u
z-o-e
bo zo like that's my bow bozo that's
real or his name's beau
maybe maybe maybe um
long time homie here never had a
question read
this is a couple we'll run through them
because they're all in that same realm
do you or does anyone your family use
the phrase um
blessing in the skies
which is really bad it's a blessing in
disguise really in the skies though how
about escape goat
irregardless and nip it in the butt
i still i know it's bud
which i learned like about a year ago
but i'll still say butt snip it in the
butt i picture like a little kid where
are you going to nip him in the butt
type thing i don't know
shut him up yeah just like hey [ __ ]
you know like a smack i thought to stop
whatever he was doing that was my logic
it's not good
also too my sister thought it was play
it by year
really yeah
i thought it was uh
um
what does it flesh it out
well this i think can go either we've
talked about this is like a big [ __ ]
writing let's flush it out or flush it i
thought it was flush it out let's flush
it out
yeah it's flesh it out i think yeah like
put some meat on it yeah exactly beef it
up beef it up right t-bone what do you
say
flesh it out flesh like flesh of my
flesh blood of my blood yeah like add
head massage
how about the bathroom
over here
i came up with on the other day i was
telling kippy instead of saying
allegedly from now on i'm gonna say a
legendary like it's a legend
who knows it's a legend
that's all trash that's all [ __ ]
things your aunts would say
you know or a dirtball cousin yeah for
sure it's a blessing in disguise you
gotta hit by a car what are you talking
about no but they're saying blessing in
the skies
oh my god yeah not uh we know the term
blessing in disguise which is trashy
to begin with yeah that's somebody who's
real hemmed up yeah well i lost my feet
my [ __ ] arm fell off it's a blessing
in disguise
like no the queen's not saying yeah
you're tanking over here is what's
happening you're trying to [ __ ] put a
positive spin on it so they fired me and
they threw me out and uh she left and
took the kids but really it's a blessing
in disguise
shout out all the mommies out there
otherwise i wouldn't have found these
good fellas at buffalo wild wings
the other good morning
um
can't be let's talk about the good
people at mint mobile mint mobile yeah
don't act like you don't know them love
you don't act like you're not already a
customer i'm big mobile family over here
huge mint mobile family over there at
the ryan household 15 bucks a month how
do they do it there's got to be a catch
here's the thing
you're a bozo there is no catch nope
they go right to you so they can pass
the savings on to you yeah uh mint
mobile's best offer of the year is here
for a limited time buy any three-month
plan and get three months for free what
uh by going online eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes significant savings on to you
three months that's bonkos how are we
paying for this stop the show cutting
out the middleman like like the big man
said uh my wife uses mobile has been for
years so it's just it only makes it
right that they are a sponsor it's it's
easy peasy there's no contracts
you sign up it's out there it is there's
no hidden fees it is legit fifteen
dollars a month so for a limited time
buy any three month mint mobile plan and
get three months free by going to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com
garbage cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month mintmobile.com garbage
dewey helix mattresses helix mattresses
helix
mattresses yeah you want to know what's
great about them what you're not walking
around some mattress store like an idiot
nope tripping over things
not knowing what you're getting some
shyster trying to lock you into some
twin bed with probably nope
bones in it or something sure all right
you go to helix.com you take the quiz
two minutes two minutes you take the
quiz whether you sleep heavy you sleep
light you sleep hot you sleep cold or if
you sleep like a big fat pig like me
they still got you covered yeah uh the
good folks at over there at helix were
nice enough to send me and my lady one
we took the two minute quiz we're a
twilight twilight twilight mattress
family and we loved it so much we just
upgraded to the king king size look at
that
uh and it's so i used our i used our
promo code i used our to what
save a couple of bucks plus we want our
beaks on the back end sweet uh so just
go to helixsleep.com garbage take the
two minutes quiz they'll match you with
a customized mattress give you the best
sleep of your life i'm telling you guys
i love it it was a game changer uh
10-year warranty plus you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up if you don't love it but
i'm telling you you're going to love it
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep.com garbage
one more time helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners helix
sleep.com garbage dewey
this one's in the same realm uh there's
two same guy no different guy um but
it's it's it's with insane's right uh
this is from mcb when something doesn't
scan at the grocery store will you say
well i guess it's free huh
that's trash
we're in the trust tree here i'm gonna
be honest i found myself doing that i
don't know why it's like a dad joke as
you get older i don't know why do you
steal it
what do you mean do you just put it in
the thing
no i'm saying when they're scanning it
and they're like oh it's not ringing i
thought i was thinking self-checkout no
no no he throws it in the bag no no i'm
an honest man no i don't i don't i'm not
i give a hey how are you good to see you
thank you for everything i'm not making
small talk i try i don't want a small
talk with you i know someone has been on
the other side of that you know
you [ __ ] hate people yeah shut up
it's the same thing with when there's an
empty plate you got to clear it from a
table i hated it that did you i know
that well that's this is this is from
will cam a little projection there i
think uh this is from will campbell uh
when you eat at a restaurant
will you say things like no when the
waiter cut when the waiter comes over
and asks for anything else will you or
any of your family members go well how
about a million dollars oh god
if i got a couple in me i'll have fun
really
who the [ __ ] are you you're not even
paying yes i am now yeah now you've paid
for three dinners with your family oh
with my fat nose they've all been they
have i'm not paying for my family really
you took the piece out to that that
wildwood uh dump you took her to win you
threw a couple of cheesesteak egg rolls
and some nicey wines in her i don't
think i did you did i remember you
telling me you took and i paid you you
bought the apps or something like that
no no yeah they keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut yeah
when a working man comes over to the
table oh i
[ __ ] hear you that just offended me
so much as someone who does all the work
around here as someone who's made your
money
that offended me that's why i keep my
mouth shut so much
um what do you say
no i don't have it's not i'm not like i
don't have like go two bits i don't have
a i don't have a closer for the [ __ ]
chat i walked up to a table one time
the apps are coming out you're checking
your notes yeah i'm like you got to work
on some new stuff early on in the meal
the main course hit them with the goods
i do the sex stuff after dessert i need
a good bit for a moscow mule huh
somebody hey comrade i had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] once more
yo shout out to to benny down at
skankfest who came up to me and demarco
yeah
he comes up to me he goes you got any
snake bits and i was like what i was
like no dude
he was like we've been calling it snake
fest for the past two days and i'm only
doing snake material and i've done about
20 and i'm all dry
that's awesome guest
he's a good hang on he's a great hand
he's a good ship
i had this one guy uh the
the confidence
when it's always an uncle
okay or like you know a cousin it's not
the guy paying the guy paying it's you
know the mom the dad the kids and like
another couple and you can just tell
when you walk up you know this [ __ ]
jerk-off is in pain and he's going to be
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i walked out to a table and he goes i
bet you know what's good here
no that guy's great
was it me
no that guy's a good that guy's a good
[ __ ]
he goes in there throwing heat
i said your wife
that dumb broad you're with
yeah i know it is tough i try not to do
it but it is the thing as i get older i
don't know why it's like that corny dad
joke thing happens i don't want to but i
guess like you a small talk guy kipp i
am not you're a small talk guy i'm not i
hate it so don't get stuck in here in
the elevator no
i do have a couple of good elevator bits
so if you want to get into it
penthouse please not only is kippy not a
small talk guy he knows how to weaponize
it because we were in raleigh north
carolina i'm getting into an uber to go
to the club and kippy's closing the door
and
the guy goes what do you do and kippy
goes he's a comedian
you better not get [ __ ] lippy with me
i'll make your ride a living hell dude
he's a comedian he loves to chat
he loves talking to people how about it
hey how are you thank you very much
appreciate you keeping moving yeah i
don't um i don't like the small talk at
all i i i wish that you know
uh i like barbers that don't really
speak a whole bunch of english because
they don't ask you questions shut up the
ball it's like dude i'm not i didn't
come here to [ __ ] if i've been i would
get it if i've been going to the same
guy
for [ __ ] 30 years i got your balls
rubbing on my elbow [ __ ] i kind of
like that of course
there's one dude where i go i go to this
place on 57th street thick piece uh no
he's a new guy
it feels like he had a python wrapping
around you
there's a snake pit i shouldn't be i
shouldn't be able to tell he's
uncircumcised
from a [ __ ] standard cut
um
from a stanford cat
from a blowout yeah i mean i'm not even
getting my hair washed you know what i
mean i shouldn't be able to tell you
he's how do you feel about that still
got the hooded monk how do i feel about
why how do you feel have you ever gotten
your hair washed when you got a haircut
oh yeah yeah well there was this place
with uh i used to go on the upper east
side when i worked over there if you go
to a salon this was yeah so at least
it's nice
i would barbershop
i had oh i would never no i would only
do it if it was an attractive lady okay
you know um
but like i'm not having some [ __ ] you
just i'm not having charlie wash my hair
you know what i mean get the [ __ ] out of
here
[ __ ] sick breath blowing in my face
no [ __ ] chain hanging down oh yeah
that was a great king of queens [ __ ] i
can taste your cross get out of here do
you ever see that king of queens they
all go get their head they all go get
their hair washed and it's just you know
a woman who's well endowed on a low-cut
shirt and they all like it and then they
cuts too she was sick or whatever and
it's like it's it's a guy with his chain
he's like ah so how long you been
working for ips or whatever
um but i used to go to this place on the
upper east side
um
but i worked over there
uh it was like 40 something bucks for a
cut which is pricey price 45. hey you
know you're getting a shampoo getting a
shampoo you would go and it was these
two russian two russian broads who were
busted but very nice
um
so it wasn't like an attractive thing it
wasn't like i was like going to like
google them or ogle them or whatever it
is um did you choose that word
specifically because they were russian
what oogle or ogle no and what's that
word that word is like you were oogling
at them
oggling at them i don't think that's
right it's oogling
now i don't either way i don't like it
it sounds real listen here you red
[ __ ]
um that bozo is trying to start up some
trouble i would go and they would give
me uh they would pour your whiskey
they're like oh you want a whiskey i'm
like i sure do
cup two tree jamos on the rocks getting
your hair cut like what are you going to
bed afterwards
who's
drinking whiskey when they're getting a
haircut i don't know it was great it was
like these these two ladies ran a fine
establishment they would wash her and
like then i would get my hair they'd be
like oh you want to wash your hair and
i'm like no because i'm also very like i
don't want to put anybody out just give
me the standard [ __ ] she's like wash
your hair it's dumb that they wash it
before wash it after right get all that
[ __ ] out of there i know but that's a
shower that way i can hit the club i
know i don't like doing that at all i've
done it a handful of times i need one
now we've discussed this in depth
the worst trash you can do it right
though if you [ __ ] you got to take a
change of a shirt
like if i was going to come here get my
hair cut so i'm saying there's ways to
mitigate the disgustingness of it but
you got to jump into when they say to me
do you want a little product in there
i'm like what am i a [ __ ] animal no
go like a [ __ ] child every time i say
no i'm gonna go home and shower yeah i
don't want your [ __ ] barbershop gel
from [ __ ] 1983. the key we'll take
something it was a little depth i will
take some of that blue gatorade
[Laughter]
take the edge off a little bit i'm a
little dehydrated
a take a riptide rush and a [ __ ]
mustache comb
um you brought that up those combs
somewhere and somebody commented on them
they said they knew what i was talking
about yeah yeah it's like a it's like
it's like an oval or your palm yeah and
it's got like a little i don't know if
it goes like over your finger or
something yeah
yeah
back in the in the 80s those things
did not sell yeah they were always they
were always just sitting there but it
goes back to the place i go now the guy
i got a revolving there's like it's a
big spot
at any given time there's about five or
six guys in there probably six
and i'll go to like three of them all
give me decent cuts and it's kind of
whoever's available
oh man in this one time not too long ago
a couple times ago i went as a new guy
and he's got the full leather [ __ ]
apron like he's like a butcher oh dude
he's got like leather wristbands
all of his gear is gold
bartender's wearing that [ __ ] i'm like
this guy's gonna [ __ ] stink and sure
as [ __ ] dude he's got me all [ __ ] up
like midway through it's a dicey
situation over there listen yeah and
when you walk in you you specifically
you need a guy with game seven face yeah
he'll be like this is this is i'm here
this is what we play i've got my ten
thousand hours yeah i'm ready to paint
my masterpiece how are you feeling any
trouble at home yeah
you feel hydrated
take some of the gatorade cause one
misstep
i feel like every time i go it's gonna
be the last one ruin you for a couple of
weeks i go i might just i might he might
be like i'm done i might have to go take
it all off dude ever i've been thinking
about that every day for like three
years
but it's looking better
in the past couple of weeks oh the money
makes you more attractive
that's the wallet i've seen you go real
when they go real high over the years on
you that's happened once or twice yeah i
was thinking about that today
you know because i was trimming up
around my ears and i was going oh i need
a haircut but i was i was like i'll go
early but i'm like i'm not gonna shower
i don't wanna i don't want that so i was
gonna go today um
but if you ever see two it's a bad look
it's just really a fat guy thing like if
you would look
very normal with it now where they just
go straight like no sideburns just like
from the airline over and you're like
dude did your wife do this what is
happening a couple of dads back in the
90s used to rock that because there was
a couple of baseball players
that went no sideburns which was cool
though they're young athletes
psycho yeah no side you got to have a
little something uh-huh and you can
always tell when you try to tighten it
up at home because the rest is heavy i i
do that all the time clean around the
ears you're like dude this is it doesn't
look the same i haven't gotten a haircut
in like six months i never go anymore i
just do a little trip over the years and
i said keep it moved yeah well you got
to load your your long hair yeah but
like the no haircut haircut like if i
just let this grow out it would be like
you gotta [ __ ] do something i'm
debating
uh since i start with the trainer
december 1st
buzzing it off going full wrestling mode
don't buzzing it all off you don't look
great well what's okay but here's the
thing i'm baking a cake why would i put
the icing on the cake when the cake's
not done
buzz it until i get out of [ __ ]
training camp
listen
the matter for you should not be dessert
love it let's go shaved head foley we'll
turn you into a bandana guy headband guy
let's fire it up like the car king on
[ __ ] history channel oh like rambo
son ooh okay rambo didn't have a shaved
head he had long hair
it was curly it was gorgeous
i mean what are we talking about he was
known for his hair that guy was kind of
i thought you meant paul pierce then who
gives a [ __ ] i like a bandana on a guy
but i don't like when they use it when
they
when you cover they'll flap back oh yeah
what are you painting what are you doing
yeah look at that that's a tough look
um bad haircuts where'd this question
start i forget awesome
i i don't even remember oh talking oh no
you asked if i was a small but hey the
winning lottery numbers are a million
dollars the small talk
no waiter for stuff and i would say and
then i said i would pay
i would pay an extra ten dollars to be
like don't speak to me the whole uber
ride the whole haircut that's nothing
that's a little [ __ ] you just i'm
not no no i'm saying i don't do that
because that's rude but i'm saying if
that was an option hey an extra 10 bucks
and you get the the silent experience i
would sign up for that every time the
silent experience yeah real fun i don't
what do i whereas my father called it
marriage because like they'll no
[Laughter]
i have a feeling it wasn't always so
silent over there at the household to be
honest with you
god damn it
patty um
this one's bananas this is from
christopher uh ever use a red or other
colored cloth to cover a lampshade to
set ambiance
it's dangerous they can catch on fire i
know trying to get your [ __ ] on though
yeah back in the day used to do that all
the time never i've never even thought
of it well i like to keep the lighting
at a certain
degree during when uh
when the red dragon comes out
pitch black or blacker
like the blue man group keep it dark in
there
spotlight only
hey what mood are you going for in the
bedroom uh chilean mine please
more of a hunt for red october man
myself keep it dark
don't say a word they can hear you yeah
nah i don't [ __ ] with it
that's that that's changed right what i
remember in my 20s that like there you
would like when you would have sex you
would like there would be like music on
and there'd be like light like you know
like yeah it would be some kind of
lighting it'd be nice
now the news is on
i mean
you make it sound like you're at someone
else's house and they're watching the
news
like no i don't have a choice uh you're
just in the johnson's living room do you
do you make it romantic
no what
romantic
i put a little product in my hair
i'll do it before i put the rogaine in
don't touch me i got my stuff in
not to here
oh kevin pays extra for the silent
experience
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i mean mood what mood what am i doing
like rose petals what the guy's talking
about putting the putting a little thing
over the lamp shade getting at night
getting sexy in there no no all right do
you not now i just told you no but back
in the day i did
yeah but i think that's a younger thing
yeah that's not a thing now
although this one hotel i was staying in
they put on luther vander and you could
just like for like three hours they were
playing like the greatest hits in the
room but next to me and i was just like
laying in bed
somebody was getting [ __ ] first class
tickets to pound town
they were going old school too yeah slow
jams luther
fully in the 90s ready to go to pound
town and he's like hey let me hit the
boombox i get knocked out
i was lying in the grass on sunday
morning of last week
indulging in my company
it was good the 90s too because they
were quick songs now that's what i call
[ __ ] volume 20 baby 220.
play the hits let's go
hold on i got to flip the tape
i'm still flipping on the tape
there was no flipping of the tape
you got a led zeppelin song you [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of luck i'm out before the
intro
make it i make it before the post
cappystamps.comstamps.comstamps.com we
love them love them because you're not
wasting time in the post office nope
you're sending things out from the
privacy and the comfort of your own home
your home office or your small business
office which we know a lot of people out
there all smart business owners we're
two small business owners actually he is
and i work for him either way don't you
forget it we use stamps.com yeah guys
with the hectic holiday shopping traffic
why not save time and money with
stamps.com who wants to you know you got
better things to do than waiting in line
at the post office that traffic is
settling back in too they're hectic this
time of year i mean what are we doing
just though from home it's easy peasy uh
you're a smart guy you listen to this
podcast smart guy or gal jointstamps.com
of course uh we use it we sent out all
the all the merch with it it's easy
peasy got the printer
just need the internet and if you sign
up with promo code garbage for a special
offer that includes four-week trial free
postage digital scale no long-term
commitments required i'm gonna say that
one more time get a pencil write it down
promo code garbage for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts uh just go to
stamps.com click the microphone at the
top of the home page enter code garbage
one more time top of the home page click
the microphone promo code garbage do it
kippy like a little dad grass i like to
dab on a little dead grass yeah i like a
little dad grass too remember when i was
a kid
i used to smoke so much weed
that i get so paranoid yeah panicky pat
like i mean
panic now that i'm older i still enjoy
dabble every once in a while take the
edge off and that grass is the right fit
for the age that i'm at and where i'm at
in my life i don't want to be all
freaked out and paranoid i just want to
relax i want to take the edge off a
little bit i want to have a glass of
wine not a whole bottle of golden
schlager yeah uh that grass is legal
organic smokable hemp that relaxes your
body and mellows your mind
100 organic pre-rolled joints are very
low in thc and high in cbd so you can
enjoy the effects of cbd while keeping
your head clear throw the pearl jam on
listen listen to uh yeah rusted root you
get to chill out without getting stoned
you know what i mean all that grass
products are federally legal for ages 21
and over and it ships right to your door
anywhere in the good old u.s of a uh
whether you're looking for a new buzz or
a chill way to enjoy an old favorite
daggrass will leave you in a euphoric
mood right now digress is offering our
listeners 20
off your first order when you go to
dadgrass.com garbage go to dadgrass.com
20 off your first order i'm gonna say
one more time that's digress.com garbage
do it
oh
that's a good [ __ ] time my belt is
digging into my stomach right now so
[ __ ] bad
it's [ __ ] brutal why are you wearing
a belt i'm back on belts i could i can i
believe it or not well it seems painful
so i'm saying why don't you you know you
just because you can doesn't mean you
have to well yeah it's because my fat
gut hangs over but i'm back in pants i
saw you were wearing jeans
how nice of a friend
give me as much [ __ ] [ __ ] as i catch
you this is something mean to you that
you would never do
i couldn't believe you did it i love you
to death i appreciate it he's out of
pure embarrassment
i was trying to save myself we're about
to go perform at a theater we're
backstage at the gramercy theater uh kfc
uh radio doing a live podcast uh-huh kfc
and feidelberg [ __ ] they murdered it
[ __ ] awesome place was packed
unbelievable these guys are the [ __ ]
best
um
but we were doing a little thing on
there and i just had started wearing i i
fit in in my lucky jeans that i bought
at dxl maybe like six months ago i
bought them and i didn't fit into them
but it's not like anything dramatic but
they fit sure it really they get that
button and it's [ __ ]
um
but they're long they're too long
so i rolled them up like kippy does
but mine were looking terrible which i
can crush for in the comments last week
and uh now you actually
don't listen to them you i'm not
listening to these bonuses
it was on the patreon show or not
youtube from your knees down you're
pretty attractive i'm not going to lie
especially when you've got the foot in
the ankle your eyebrows up you're doing
okay that's my bit uh
but they look stupid and there was no
way this is this is literally how
how big the gulf was it was that big but
like also like two inches fat
and i was just like dude yeah i'm like
hey man he goes how do these look and i
go i gotta be honest with you not great
you know what i mean like but we're in
triage mode here we're about to go out
there's not much we can we can't get
your new bear pants they don't look good
he's like you gotta fix it i'm like i
can't cause he couldn't and i was like
would you physically fix it and he got
down on his knees and [ __ ] fixed my
pants i'm about to start crying i love
you buddy it's the belt i think
[Laughter]
it's really cutting me so take it off i
can't what do you mean because it's a
pain in the ass it's a fat guy belt and
you have to like bend it a certain way
it's [ __ ] lasers involved
union rules
hey i need a couple of stage hands up
here give me a couple of teamsters
what's the iot story those guys back on
the job yet or what did you find hoffa
yet i need three good guys
i heard you paint belts
i heard you buckle belts
oh god uh
kid hit me up josh josh hit me up sure
started out 600 he hit me up i 20 pounds
to hit you up dude he hit me up i said
buddy i'm trying my best he shred it
yeah shred it i know i couldn't believe
it was the same guy yeah pretty good
shout out to josh can't chipotle
what are we doing
sent me a nice message it's awesome 6
20. that last
that last that also gave me the idea
that i got a little wiggle i knew that's
what you this guy's six
i got two more i got two more bills to
go oh what a ride that would be um yeah
i would i would quit i think you could
quit
yeah that's discrimination against fat
that wasn't a word discrimination
it's discriminating against when you're
mean ending a ditch
irrigation anybody all right um
back to the cues hold on what was i
gonna say oh that last uh fat chord
phase two on patreon that just dropped
or at this point probably two a week or
two ago um really hit a lot of people
yeah a lot of messages and i said send
them to the big man go to the big man
yeah let him know
december 1st we're starting back in
training mcrib's coming back
god damn it it is back
um got a real good vibe from the trainer
too good luck i know i saw the pics yeah
i'm gonna see if maybe i'm gonna talk to
him maybe we could do a little something
this is all patreon stuff what are we
doing about it yeah i know having a good
time it's just all patreon stuff
you actually we don't do we do you know
whatever uh all right this one's from tj
while we're talking about the mcrib
everybody ever pooping at mcdonald's
yeah
yeah hell yeah uh-huh they have the
private quarters mcdonald's bathroom
ain't nothing to shake us depends where
you're at they got corporate rules every
20 minutes they got to send somebody in
there yeah but they're not always
[ __ ] up to snuff and usually the
person that they have on that detail
that's their only detail but same guy
like moves the bags and stuff i
understand but also flipping new york
ones depends on what neighborhood you're
in sure if you go to one in like [ __ ]
around here there's one over there on
[ __ ]
the west 4th street won oh it was
unbelievable good terrible yeah the one
there was one of the east villages
it was one of my proper low like a low
point in my life was we were [ __ ]
super struggling because you're changing
seven years ago i was changing at the
east the one on the east village on like
14th and first or whatever and that
place was a war zone yeah i remember
shaving into chipotle
uh in the east village in between
auditions sarah do you want extra meat
or not
um you were in line um
but uh
i was changing and i had to [ __ ] at the
same time and there was like people
banging on the door it was okay it was
like that scene from a pursuit and
happiness where they were [ __ ]
pursuit of that pursuit of happiness
where they were going after them ball
pits are trash
i i've never been in one
ever ever hid no that doesn't make sense
it hadn't taken yet
it hadn't taken by the time i was
growing up never been in a ball pit
never been in a ball pit
well i know what we're doing for our
next patreon goal turning this place
into going in one oh all right yeah you
can buy those balls
that i'd be interested in
i don't know well i mean sure
put sand in here it's gonna be tough to
ship those things right
[ __ ] bezos we'll send them you can
buy them i know you can buy them because
my cousin was gonna my cousin had like a
recessed living room he bought this old
house and had like a recessed like
little conversation pit or something and
his kids were literally he's like i'm
just gonna fill it with [ __ ] bull he
didn't but he had so sweet yeah i'm like
that's pretty [ __ ] cool that's cool
that's a cool thing cool out of the year
right there it's nice
to 200 ball pit balls at 27 bucks a clip
we could fill this thing up for like a
couple hundred per ball no for 200 balls
but that's not a lot that's probably
like nothing the table if that
it would cost thousands of dollars to
fill this room
or we'd have to build a pen
and then do that maybe we just put like
a fence up around here and put the table
in one that's what we're doing no if
we're broadcasting from the ball pit if
we were ever spending money the one
thing i would want in here
dunk tank
that would be fun
have toby in a dunk tank every time
every time he bombs we get to throw a
ball at him whoa
now we're talking
are you guys familiar with the milkshake
of death
were you poisonous in a couple of weeks
yeah right no no it's like it's like
it's always skate or die with this kid i
know it's like it's like a bit where you
know you have a bunch of gross stuff and
you put it in a blender and then you
have like a competition loser has to
drink the gross stuff right i did that i
didn't know that's what it was called
but we did it as kids yeah like
sleepovers and stuff did you it's like
if you lost in the video games you had
to drink the concoction that's it
[ __ ] that i've always wanted to do ball
pit of or dunk tank of death
where are you just
well uh we're talking yeah well you just
filled up with the nastiest [ __ ] you can
find tuna
mayo whatever and then loser gets dunked
in the dunk tank of
this guy's so extreme
hey lay off the mountain dew will you
t-bone fun kid in high school i bet huh
yeah so if there's any rad podcasts out
there they're trying to they're looking
to hang 10. you got some extra cans of
tuna laying around
get out of here
dunk tank of death
those are for like fundraisers and stuff
like that pull it back a little bit kid
have a piece of funnel cake will you
i'm from the internet generation i'm
here to get bonked dude doobie dobrik
what's his real name
dewey no
david dave dave
david dobrik david
dewey
all right let's see here what else do we
got this is i uh this is from christian
haven't had one read on the air yet do
you or anyone in your family have wild
plants or weeds growing in the gutter
from lack of cleaning the gutter on the
house that happens a lot what yeah
because it's all water like old castles
when the king dies
don't forget
clean my gutters and the vikings
as he's getting stabbed that's like grey
garden [ __ ] what
no never for sure patty foley no she
invests in her property what hap i know
but i've seen it a bunch where if
there's like a tree over like the garage
like that hangs over
all that like the seeds and all the dirt
and everything could just like it
[ __ ] they would especially if you
don't i'm i'm not saying they would have
my fat ass up on that ladder on a sunday
quicker than i could shake a stick he
collapsed like the guy on the perfect
one
how do you guys feel about the gutter
guards
we were talking about that with chrissy
d
yeah
uh yeah you gotta do you gotta do i i
used to sell them and they're all pretty
much
[ __ ] right like the self-cleaning
the whatever it's like they're all gonna
get clogged and they're fine you gotta
clean your gutters that's it and they're
[ __ ] expensive pay someone to come
over twice a year or whatever
get up you shouldn't be out there
climbing on a [ __ ] ladder you
shouldn't be doing it yourself unless
you're handy and if you've got a chimney
make sure you get that cleaned out
everybody if you're like a construction
worker or whatever and you know what
you're doing sure you're a real man yeah
but you should not you shouldn't be
[ __ ] you know
climbing up like you know hanging on the
side of a house to save 400 bucks you
know pay to get you know
pay a handyman to come do that
not a big ladder guy either
really no
don't like it don't like heights don't
like sharks
you don't like weight limits either
i don't want to go up in that letter
anyway yeah
keep your shirt on we need to go on a
ladder
all right this one's from misty
never had a question yet red um and this
one is uh
i read it as a thinker how many facebook
accounts do you have or have you had oh
my god if you have more than one you're
crazy that's what i'm saying it's either
well as a comedian or like a artist to
have a page or whatever yeah of course
but i'm saying just a straight facebook
profile because my mom's had a couple
for stalking purposes well that well
this is what i'm saying there's a couple
of reasons it's either stalking purposes
which means you're a [ __ ] hardcore
creepo
or
hardcore magnet propaganda you're you're
posting some things that you're getting
booted and you're starting another one
either way it's not a fantastic look
dude
my mom looks like a serial killer on
facebook no picture
and the worst english you would ever see
uh-huh looks great
no period space space space love you
space space space
yeah
there was one not that long ago looks
great beautiful children
she was gonna eat them i cannot wait to
have them for dinner
yeah it's tough
the no picture denise is denise is on
there uh
it's all kids it's all pic kids look
great you know
a couple of misspellings here and there
whatever you know not great punctuation
same thing these broads are getting old
kooky you know what i mean they're
losing it and they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't know what she doesn't give a
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care
yeah
my dad is the greatest instagram of all
time the caption is just exactly what
the photo is it'll be like a rainbow
over a building it'll be like a nice
rainbow
they just don't get social media
they just don't get it
they don't my mom shares everything
everything yeah things that have been
shared ten thousand times shares it you
know she get caught up in the if you
share this the money will come into your
hands yeah i think we've talked about
this recently yeah she's big chain
letter broad really yeah damn yeah
that and i'll pray for you it's like the
same thing to her you know what i mean
she thinks if you're you know i also
don't think she knows what facebook is
remember remember for a while they did
the thing like if this doesn't get it'd
be like some veteran from world war one
yeah
like sitting in a wheelchair his [ __ ]
faces have fallen off glasses are on
sideways and there'd be some
attention-seeking [ __ ] [ __ ]
standing next to him and they got him
holding up a sign if this gets a million
likes oh you know whatever yeah
uh yeah that's bad what he one facebook
account
that's it unless you get locked out or
something maybe a glitch but
you shouldn't be operating where you
need multiple either you're super
[ __ ] creepy or you know
pull it back with the political stuff
like myspace on the other hand that was
the wild west yeah
i mean
that was that that was international
wars we came to i mean facebook got big
when i my freshman year of college
that's when kids are all doing it that's
when it hit like that was when you were
like i didn't know what it was until i
got the freshman year of college and
they were like well yeah i'll find you
on facebook that's what it was just kids
on there it was just it was just it was
you had to have
dot edu and it wasn't even all schools
it was just like most schools
and then
they allowed uh community colleges i
remember we were being like what the
[ __ ] about the beginning of the end
and i remember this kid joined
who like had no
who didn't even apply to go to school
you know what i mean i was like this
guy's guy i'm like i'm out we've jumped
the shark type thing
this used to be a cool little club you
know what i mean you were like oh this
is a thing you never went to community
college right what now
oh yeah and look at you you're a
business owner i'm a businessman get
yourself a kipp almost international no
[ __ ]
you'll be in you'll be an international
that was my major finally
if i text you to tell you to retweet the
link while you're in france yeah
international businessman conducting
business two different continents right
there like that boom baguette now
on your myspace page did you have a song
that would auto play didn't have myspace
never did i heard some guy talking about
it when i was in uh senior year and i'm
like that sounds
wildly [ __ ] corny kick rocks
i heard you've had animated gifs of like
dollar signs and just that was my that
was my music platform it was my space my
songs are up there find it t-bone i was
still there i would put them up it's
still there on a regular basis i
remember this girl from high school hit
me up it was all new to us this guard
from high school hit me up and i was
like yeah the record label did that and
put it together
real [ __ ] douchebag you said the
record label did what she hit you up hey
it looks good or like yeah like you know
you used it as an out of like i don't
know what they're doing yeah exactly
that was the team yeah exactly
trying to [ __ ] bang this broad what
do you want from me [ __ ] young kid
put a napkin over the lamp you got
yourself you're gonna do the
the promo things that i did on the imac
did you find it toby found it
i don't think the songs will play
you love the glory days i thought i was
doing it myspace
as a little you know community back and
forth
do you get any anything pop from there
you know what happened you make you make
any good connections
oh they won't play dude
copyright infringement toby i don't want
you downloading it put it on your dick
doc old school i don't know senior class
trip is pretty bumping 181 plays
15 years
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
he'll be on the charts in no time i
thought timberlake was bringing that
back i could have a whole new career
what myspace yeah wasn't he i don't know
wasn't he doing that one of those nerds
was
man
you also do you used to do some really
wonky [ __ ] on youtube too when i first
met you
oh yeah
man
i was trying what do you want from me no
you had the biggest dork haircut i
remember and i was like a mullet oh no i
thought it looked cool i know you think
a lot of things look cool yeah that's
kind of your you know yeah that's your
cross to bear my thing
but i remember genuinely thinking
i thought you were cool when i met you
and then i saw your youtube page and i
was like this is that i was like oh i
gotta rethink it where are you are you
locked in with me now [ __ ] tough
break bozo now i'm bringing him back
what do you got you got some play
no it's not gonna spin the record kid
nah i won't play it's it it's all there
but it's like
you don't have any profile pictures or
anything it seems like it was deleted
but it's still up somehow mm-hmm
you have there's no pics up there
there was one there was like a picture
of me like going like that
that
yeah i was a [ __ ] loser i don't know
what do you want from me hey pretty cool
now
[Laughter]
in my medical belt
yeah and my prescription belt i have on
my orthopedic reversible belt oh my god
it's fat on both sides
now that's a good piece of business
right there
we're tanking
that's great
um all right let's do one or two morning
get up out of here let's do it baby this
one's just got questions this up i gotta
tell you give our questions we've
covered this a bunch this one the way
it's just funny uh so from kyle homey
hasn't had a question answer or question
red uh
what's the most garbage video vehicle
you can take it to hold on let me start
over what is the most garbage vehicle
you can take to prom and why is it the
short bus that i
took that is why bad luck did they rent
it i don't know oh my god either way if
you rented it any school provided
transportation is terrible but you guys
[ __ ] on me you and reggie [ __ ] on me for
driving myself
i took my mom's car yeah we cleaned it
and also it was it was a white nissan
maxim it was hot
took it to prom
yeah it was an acid at the time but
still that's not cool
uh no that's what limousines are for are
for prom dude you get it's like 30 bucks
you and 38 kids all pile into a [ __ ]
navigator that has bad shocks a bus is a
tough look
school a yellow school a party bus is
all right you know what i always thought
was pretty pretty trashy in a weird way
you're gonna disagree with me on it
because i guarantee
i would say 99.9 of your family that's
gotten married especially your our
generation definitely had one of these i
know what you're saying because i know
every single person in philly is big
got him
the trolley yeah trash
i don't think so
over it absolute trash and what party
trolley what the driver was always a
weirdo
uh
sure and it was always like my cousins
like the groom's buddies from college
they were like a little this guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude you genuinely don't
like anybody it's crazy that's always
true
thanks for having fun
i don't like the driver of the [ __ ]
uh
how many of you probably
won okay the drivers were always this
this is the h moly [ __ ] i've done one
thing once and i've i now hate every and
like i'm not it's always your cousin's
buddies from who are probably good guys
they're cool and they're everyone's
hanging out having drinks i get it
what's the i was into my music back then
i'm sorry yeah hey guys have you heard
of what my record label made for me on
myspace you should check it out i gotta
i got i got something calling i got a
new something brewing called senior skip
day it's a real doozy
it's about lisa's lisa jay broke my
heart do you ever meet her [ __ ] dumb
broad anyway this driver seems like a
dork huh
meanwhile i have a mullet and i'm 33 and
i think it's cool i remember i got drunk
at a wedding one time when i was in that
well when i was in that phase and i
thought i was going to be like a rock
star
uh
drunken any rock star fantasy left
dude the goddamn comedy jam that's all i
think about i know what i'm saying do
you think when i'm listening to a song i
pick dude i [ __ ] love that but that's
proper fantasy i get that but i'm saying
that's fantasy is there anything of you
being like i'm gonna dust off the guitar
and get back at it
and sunny day my way out of here no it's
not sunny day i still think i should
maybe do something with into the night
me and tommy were talking about me
making a music video
but we're gonna see you know
what kind of fun thing we can get
we're gonna have a pitch meeting with
you yeah well hey
i'll save everybody i'll save everybody
12 seconds no
i'll save everybody 12 seconds
wait
i'll i will admit one of the douchiest
things i've ever done in my life oh god
i want to know what you think it is
because i got about 40 for you i was at
a wedding
uh i think i was living in north
carolina at the time
and
uh i came up for a wedding or something
like that i was dancing with my aunt
[ __ ] twerking drunk as [ __ ]
and i was like i don't want you to worry
about anything i'm going to put all of
our all the kids through college oh my
gosh it was like a vice president at the
time her husband yeah yeah it was
probably worth about two three mil yeah
at the wedding did not have a gift
[Laughter]
and got so drunk i started crying in the
car on the way home that had to be one
of my dad's lowest points was watching
you oh
dude
what set you off who knows
i don't know
[ __ ] 19 [ __ ] yinglings i don't
know this next one goes out to lisa it's
called pizza day
it's called [ __ ]
it's called sack lunch
[Laughter]
shout out to sack lunch brilliant movie
yeah
yeah i sucked i don't really tell you uh
you didn't suck you were a dork for sure
sure
you always had delusions of grandeur
sure
i'm gonna put that's what amazes me most
about it i meant it though
i'm not discred this isn't [ __ ] on
you by any means well i mean
i mean i'm publicly i'm publicly making
fun of you for sure
hey let's get this clear i want to go on
record i'm making fun of you but it's
more of an anal analyzation that i see
and
you
you've always you wanted to be the hero
always
not it's listen not even when in fact
you're a born villain
does the joker know he's a bad guy
um
no i always have like no
no i always i i role is like i'm going
to put all the grandkids through college
no one thinks like that dude nobody
nobody thinks like that's you i always
had a sense of like family pride like
you know what i mean like i want to be
the one that's going to me while your
brother hates you
who was killing it on wall street yeah
yeah it was dragging me around yeah
meanwhile you were doing a [ __ ]
student film in north carolina
listen he's closing deals on on the
exchange wait ted was hot back then wait
till senior class trip hits 182 plays
i'm really gonna cash in that poor kid
my brother dealing with me
same with my brother dealing with me no
i singer singer songwriter new york city
oh dude my brother was like what the
[ __ ] is this kid doing
i've seen i can see
it yeah
he's just
he's spent on you oh yeah yeah
so
because i'm getting there as well
oh you're getting there with me i'm
gonna be like in six listen if we
weren't about to go on vacation i'd be
your brother in about four days
just cold and dead to you
yeah hey that was a good time
but i got t-boned i think i got a couple
more weeks with him
you probably got about three years left
in tebow yeah t-bone's good everybody
else you've gone to the well on yeah i
can i i i i can sense when he gives me
what i want tebow yeah when i get to
open up my you me and him are little
side chats sure yeah i mean i get to
open up a little crazy on them uh-huh so
it's nice yeah it's good we got we got a
very dysfunctional family working here
but it's working that's the way we like
it and we love you guys and we
appreciate yours and i'll tell you what
what we'll see you next week peace